e aí galera capricho ronaldo para vocês
aqui muito suado é porque você está
situado enquanto milhões quanto antes
houve falha no amor hoje é quanto isso
doze né você também fala que hoje
assistiu o filme que chega primeiro
ensaio já nos cinemas é o rio logo o
filme no filme com essas coisas loucas
adolescente acontece todo mundo
aconteceu comigo aconteceu com você ou
vai acontecer com você foi muito feliz
pela conquista foi infeliz nas pessoas
que aconteçam coisas parabéns christian
pelo seu filme realmente está do cará e
totalmente está cooptando com cristo no
cinema já se viu falar que coisas muito
legais acontecer duas coisas ruins
aconteceram em 2006 porém coisas muito
legais acontecendo na minha vida
aconteceu muita coisa boa e acabou 2016
não tive tempo de agradecer a vocês pelo
ano que foi o ano que que a gente
cresceu e que falar a gente tem que nós
eu sei vocês não só pessoa que eu sou o
windows ou o maior do tube vocês em mim
quando muita coisa porque tem um sonho
em fazer graça mas tudo bem mas vocês em
mim talvez até não tivesse uma pessoa
que está fazendo graça que nem eu faço
pra você então uma coisa nossa é tudo
nossa alegria nossas piadas são nossas
risadas são nossos vídeos o nosso canal
é nosso dinheiro é meu quem é para mel
do ataque o trabalho e acima de tudo
acima de qualquer brincadeira assim de
qualquer piada eu sou muito muito grato
a vocês eram de verdade sou grato a
vocês que essas empresas vão gerar lá
pulando e corri o índice mas não é só
isso minha família que passar
dificuldade do [ __ ] hoje ele bem por
trazer mais amigos meus a trabalhar
comigo por trazer fama trabalhar comigo
então é [ __ ] também procuram uma pessoa
muito carismática e muito simpática que
você está assistindo aí um dia lhe
tratei mal você pode ter certeza que eu
estava num dia ruim e não estar num dia
bom estou sempre procurando fazer o
melhor sempre procurando emprego você em
todas as redes sociais não só no twitter
você consegue instagram tem um vídeo sem
gols entre uma foto engraçada que estou
fazendo lá pra fazer graça no facebook
você foi ao show do trio agradecer por
ter comparecido ao show 2007 foi em 121
cidade em ser mais de 200 shows 200
shows como as inventou enquanto a cidade
é que às vezes é uma cidade e faz muitos
sessões como fiz em brasília onde
sessões
eu fiz da outra vez eu fui ontem 5 60
mil pessoas jv 50 mil pessoas e 36 estão
demais é muito legal estou passando e
sei lá de carro na rua passando as
pessoas passam de carro e pararam
eleitoral vai fazer hoje vai torcendo
por mim isso me deixa muito feliz me
deixa empolgado para gravar mais vídeo
assim hoje eu sou um cara muito feliz
dinheiro não é tudo na vida não pode ser
o dia que pudesse aceitar a perguntar
você não conseguir dormir há sinais de
como é mas eu graças a deus sou feliz
assim que eu sou eu e meu relacionamento
como na minha vida profissional como com
a minha família e eu sei que eu posso
não ser isso a vida inteira que tudo é
passageiro dinheiro passa o carro passa
na asa passa tudo passa mas se isso tudo
passar um dia eu gostei muito agradecido
a vocês você é muito grato a vocês a
deus por um dia eu tenho rodado no
brasil inteiro fazendo um show no brasil
inteiro os vídeos com mais visualizações
no brasil o vídeo com mais likes com as
redes sociais cheia de elogios cheio de
muito carinho que vocês me dão eu sou
muito grato por isso um dia tudo isso
acabar e alguém fosse lá me entrevistar
estava aquele programa da record e
procura o famoso onde está o inverso
muneoka vai entrevistar annapurna na
barraca de praia vendo qual coco eu
tenho certeza que vou receber repórter
com muita felicidade por estar lembrando
de um tempo que foi excepcional para mim
muito comentar um bom tempo não temos
começaram muito menos um livro por que
não são lixo não me escuta esse tipo de
comentário quando tinha 15 mil inscritos
para são luís tem 16 milhões de pessoas
de olhão disse james dean e pela chance
fez um lixo dentro daquelas e lixo a
vida entrou cowboys e lixo comentar se
fosse pobre não namorava a gata dessa
coisa se fosse cá só do vídeo namorar na
tabela com essa banda na merda gente
feliz no começo do torneio apertura me
conhece me abençoa a 6 music la se ela
me conhece acha que conhece a mulher me
conhece eu sou um cara que eu acho que a
mulher tem que ser tratada como rainha o
caio tem que ser a melhor pessoa para
sua mulher mas eu não sou um cara se eu
sou um cara que você tem que aprender
porque o cara quando faz a mulher dele
feliz ela fica feliz e quando ela fica
feliz ela retorna toda a felicidade que
ela tá pra você eu não sou eu acho
bonita fogo ea mulher gosta da fruta o
que ela gosta da sua armação a planta
não é a planta é o ato é o ato de você
lembrar passar na floricultura e lembrar
que tenham mulher carinho
feliz e despencado você compra um pouco
depois ela para a wii mas o bookess a
vai tomar no meu corpo que quanto mais
na bola quanto vai por rachas dentro tem
dinheiro pra tomar sua cervejinha depois
é como quando cerveja hoje cerveja cinco
cervejas outra cerveja sei lá se reais
46 um botão de fogo aquece e rosas em
casa dos 30 anos que terá a chance de
ver isto como um books em off leve on da
mulher
enche de felicidade um mês já que você
cometa qualquer merda respeito do
relacionamento a trocação cerveja tocar
sua coca cola trocar o seu direito à
espera do racha interno do baba o
futebol no final de semana inteirinho a
sua bebida em troca de dinheiro em
comprar rosa e depois a mulher você vai
ver a diferença que vai fazer para
deixar todo mundo pensa todo mundo todos
os fãs qualquer tipo de fã que eu sou
feliz nos abraçar todo tipo petrobras
família pelos idosos
no mês o dólar tem a foto comigo você
abraça também ampliou o cabelo em branco
sovaco pôde mas não marca nem sempre é
também o consulado com o melhor chefe do
mundo não às vezes eu dou uma chegadinha
br br o seu caso e passa por um jumento
morto às vezes para um jumento morreu
por aqui por essa br assim mas eu adoro
por nos planos do idoso meus com a
criança não sou homossexual mas muito
você é evangélico você não pode
concordar com os homossexuais conquistam
pecado deus mandou o filho dele ao mundo
jesus ele chegou pra quebrar todos os
parâmetros ele veio para mudar ele fez a
diferença paulo quando pregava paulo
pegava raça de víboras paulo tinha um
jeito de paulo quer aquele jeito de
paulo ele era o paulo copa são paulo era
top do que ele pregava do gtp legal mas
jesus ele ver com aquele jeito que
trazia paz mas jesus você não pode
trabalhar hoje porque hoje estado jesus
falava atuais do gessado agora vai
deixar o bicho morreu no buraco porque
não pode trabalhar no sábado a deixar
morrer eu vou dizer que deus não para
jesus falava no meu filho a mudar jesus
quando encontrou com maria madalena e
falou vai e não peques mais e maria
madalena deixou tudo aquilo que foi
jesus ea gente tem que ser limitado de
crise temos que sem limitador ic3 jesus
não se encontrou com nenhuma sexual na
bíblia não há passagem na bíblia que
jesus encontrou com alguém com uma
sessão tal incapaz e imitador de cristo
mas jesus não encontrou
o que a gente faz exatamente mata e não
tem o direito de julgar nem você
entender de julgar saber de jogar aqui
tem de jogar que tem todo o poder de
julgar não é eu nem você
você pode falar você tem sua opinião e
eu também tenho minha opinião você pode
falar sua opinião vai julgar julgar é
deus campo albino indígena e 12
homossexual muito obrigado por tudo que
vocês fizeram muito obrigado o ano 2016
e 2017 vai ter show se você é fã do
canal que você está me seguindo
você chegou agora e gostei aqui no
youtube está pode clicar em gostei aqui
no youtube bota lá no facebook já possui
esse vídeo eo novo muito obrigado e fica
lá em curtir se você é fã do canal não
esquece você quer no twitter sempre
esquece da rpdc vivo pelo twitter volta
lá e dar rt nesse twitter pode quebrar o
recorde rt no vídeo é nóis deus abençoe
você estamos juntos indigência albinos é
tatuados nem eu devo homossexuais negros
branco por pardo amarelo no nordeste no
peixe você quer peixe e os abençoe você
peixes emitem muito também [ __ ] meu
deus do céu te digo que iria virar um
peixe psp revela profundo oceano 13 hora
antes o horário manaus
aí eu fui para são paulo acabou o show
era para chegar a 7 hora e eu cheguei
fez um calor de verão ou foi 8 depois de
fazer show em campo grande chegou lá eu
teria chegado onde cheguei no orçamento
centro de são paulo era hora mais alguém
me ligou lá em são paulo para onde eu
sei lá no final de outono face à oração
eu sei que na noite na porta e tenho uma
foto aqui é o meu deus do céu como
remover o lixo veneno e tirando fotos na
chuva eo para buscá lo porque ia
conversar no meio da chuva
meu deus do céu
foi isso está de boa tamo junto
valeu